hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on four and today we
have a more in-depth look at the siege
game mode called breach how to play and
how to do it the most effectively as
well as an endless PvE mode coming and
the names of the new characters we're
going to beginning as well as the
faction name and a bunch of other stuff
so with that like the video feed to
enjoy subscribe if you're new I cover
the leaks the informational side of
foreign or balance changes passionate
leagues hero updates all that type of
stuff like this video in particular and
with that let's get started so as I
finished my last video I went on the
Ubisoft page and found out that there
was more info and I decided to be a good
idea to get to dedicate a separate video
to this as well that includes character
names in-depth gameplay and a
walkthrough on how to play the new siege
mode breach and an endless co-op PvE
mode possibly coming as well in the
future so first up is the characters and
as I said they are part of the Wulin
faction any first one up that is named
is called the Shaolin and he shall in
our feast warrior monks known for their
athletic and monkey-like fight style and
their prowess with a bo staff they hold
their written prayers close to them at
all times this is the bo staff god we
talked about in the last video and is
going to definitely be my new main I'm
super excited to see how the Shaolin is
going to be playing out but to continue
on we have the guy with the one-handed
sword called the T on D and E T on ER
Laurel protectors to the kings queens
and emperors
they're masters of the DAO blade at the
weapon of choice for these Royal Guards
third up is the older looking man called
Jang Joon I'm pretty sure I pronounced
that wrong but the Jang's you are
generals among the ancient Chinese
armies there are wise leaders who have
mastered the guan dal weapon and like i
said this looks very similar to Nobu
she's weapon so maybe he'll have a
similar play style to her as well and
then lastly is the female assassin and
probably the most complex name I've ever
seen in a foreigner character and I
believe it's called the nuke sia the
nuke sia our train of bodyguards and
assassins who often disguise their
talents their dance their deadly artists
of the hook swords as I said that's
going to be the characters who knows
what their move sets are going to look
like maybe we'll get that info later in
the next couple months or so who knows
but those are the names what their
weapons are and how to pronounce them
hopefully I pronounced that right as
well like I said they're part of the new
faction coming the Wulin faction we're
also going to be having some graphical
enhancements coming in the marching fire
update some include these before and
after photos I'm going to be showing on
the screen of temple garden and River 4
with the before being on the left in the
after on the right these are probably
just a few things they have done
graphically and there are probably tons
more that they have done as well
these are just
a few examples they showed on the
website next up and probably the medius
part of this whole video is the released
new siege mode and what it will look
like going over what it does and they'll
do what this video explains it what to
look out for and basically do summarize
it one team attacks the base and defeats
the king which is the big warden with
the cool armor while the defending team
prevents the attackers from raiding the
base first the attackers must push a
battering ram into the wall and destroy
the door if the defenders have anyone
within range of the battering ram it
will stop moving similar to how it was
in the campaign mission so eliminate
every defender at all costs that being
minions captains and heroes the
defending team on the other hand has to
prevent this battering ram from breaking
the gate they can either do this by
destroying the battering ram since it
has a health bar or kill enough
attackers so their ticket count runs out
because they have limited lives in this
mode the defenders do have access to a
ballista to achieve their goal but most
for this mode but if the attackers
happen to succeed they move on to area
to area to is very similar where you
must push the battering ram to the next
door except there are archers on the
side of the area slowing down your
progress speed to remove this simply
kill all the archers in the area and
then claim it as your own Archer tower
to continue forward killing all the
archers in that knot means that that is
your tower and you can get your own
archers to help in the fight and if the
defending team loses one of these towers
they lose it for the remainder of the
game
so definitely defend this as much as
possible since this is very crucial the
defenders in this area like before have
to destroy the battering ram or run the
attackers tickets dry keeping a strong
hold of the archer towers is a must to
succeed in this area for both teams but
the defenders also have a new type of
weapon to use and that is the cauldron
where you pour hot fire on top of the
battering ram to weaken its health and
killing anyone underneath you as well if
the attackers reach this far they can
move on to the final area in the map
called the king's court in this area the
attackers must defeat the King which is
the huge guy with the cool-looking armor
and he has a huge health bar as seen on
screen and does tons of damage so it
requires lots of cooperation the
defending team wins by bringing the
ticket count to zero and that's it
the king is an AI boss but that's super
hard and hits super hard so be very
careful with that and he if you're on
the defending team is like obviously
your ally
on this portion of the map that has
archer points for Archer towers
ballistas and zip lines where I'm
assuming both teams can use this to
their advantage I'm assuming if the
attackers get hold of the ballistas they
can use that to shoot the King and lower
even more same thing with the archer
points as well either way this area is
going to decide who loses or not if you
happen to get this far hopefully that
was a good in-depth look at the new game
mode breach and how to play it
effectively and also did you guys catch
it at the end warden did a unblockable
heavy warden we were confirmed maybe who
knows and then lastly is this new
endless co-op PvE mode sadly there is no
news on this other than some text that
says a new mode yet to be a review of
offer an unlimited single-player and
two-person co-op PvE content the first
thing that comes to mind is a horde mode
where in this case you and a buddy
constantly fight waves of minions
captains and heroes until you die and
you see how far you can go before you
die this is probably the most vague info
we've gotten so far so let me know what
you guys think this will be in the
comments below we may know more about
this in the next stream on Thursday so
definitely stay tuned on that if they
happen to show that info as well what
that guys it's going to be the end of
the video today hope you guys did enjoy
like the V if you did I had a lot of fun
making this video subscribe if renew I
covered the informational site a
foreigner like I've stated numerous
times before the informational side
being patch notes bound changes new game
modes new updates all that type of stuff
I like to cover here on the channel for
for honor my two most recent videos will
be on the screen if you guys don't check
that out and with that guys who bigger
yesterday and peace out you guys for
watching the video